malik sultan mahmud doesn't meet the
requirements to perform this year's hajj
in saudi arabia
a 66 year old in pakistan is one of
nearly 2.5 million muslims from around
the world
missing the annual gathering for the
second year because of the pandemic
so malik is now pinning his hopes on
going in 2022
instead
nobody can trust this life there's no
guarantee that i'll be alive
even for another second so in my heart i
wish i can do the hajj
every muslim tries to go but it is god's
fate
saudi arabia has limited numbers to just
60 000
vaccinated residents aged between 16 and
65
and it's implementing strict covert 19
measures at the holy sites
social distancing is a must even in
prayer pilgrims have also been put in
groups with a government guide to ensure
safety protocols are followed
and a new digital system has been
introduced worshipers must use a smart
card to gain entry to the holy sites
it also contains their medical history
and services for food and transport
the pilgrimage this year is happening
under exceptional circumstances
new things have been created for the
first time like online submissions for
the hajj ministry and electronic
payments
behind the scenes police are making the
most of the reduced numbers and are
testing out new technology
we receive a call in two seconds and we
pass it to the necessary authorities in
less than 45 seconds
using an advanced technical system
the hajj is one of the largest
gatherings in the world and brings in an
annual revenue of eight billion dollars
for the saudi government
but the pandemic has had a devastating
effect on businesses
especially for hajj travel agencies both
in saudi arabia and abroad
have been closed for two years now and
there's nothing that can be done about
it
we're in the process of closing the hajj
number union and handing over its file
to the ministry of labor
we ask god to end this worry this grief
and this pandemic for all muslims
for many muslims the hajj remains a
lifelong dream
and at least for those living in saudi
arabia they'll be able to fulfill it
this year al jazeera